Today, I'm going to be speaking with
Amanda Mackey, who is an attorney and also
a Republican strategist, and I'm hoping to get
some insight, Amanda, into how you see the
sort of last four years of the Republican
Party and maybe we can just work backwards.
Why do you think Trump lost in twenty 20?
I have said all along, and thank you for having
me on your show, but I have said all along I think
this election in 2020 was a referendum on the
pandemic. It was really a coronavirus election and
how some people viewed the handling of President
Trump as not wearing a mask, not enforcing that,
not pushing and promoting those policies versus
Joe Biden, who was in his basement. He was kind
of in hiding in seclusion, which be a lot of
people actually agreed with that. It was you
had to be isolated. You should be. And so I think
it was really the dichotomy of how people viewed
the pandemic and how they viewed the the response
to the coronavirus by the two different camps.
I basically agree with you. I mean, I've said
before that if you look at countries where world
leaders handled the virus well, or at least the
perception is that they did. And you talk about
New Zealand, you talk about Australia, other
places had Trump just said, hey, you know what,
we're printing Magga masks. If he had said that
on March 20th of twenty twenty and we're letting
the doctors handle this, I think he essentially
sails to reelection. And I think the proof is
and maybe here we'll start to disagree. His
major campaign promises, he didn't do any
of them. The US Mexico border wall, he added
50 miles he was going to replace Obamacare.
He didn't do it. He said he would pay off the
debt within four years. He increased it. Right.
So. So and it really didn't matter. It I don't.
And we can talk about why it didn't matter. But
I think without it, without question, if he just
handles the pandemic moderately well, he wins.
I think that he viewed his handling of
the pandemic ultimately as a success,
because you do now have three or four,
depending on the country, vaccines that
are on the market, at least in the United States.
At the end of his term, there were two vaccines on
the market, which I have always said having worked
in health care policy is the health care attorney.
I mean, that's nothing short of Nobel Peace Prize
winning. And you can't say that it's not now. You
can't just say that was all President Trump,
but certainly pushing on all the levers to get
that to market. He said that during the campaign
season and people laughed at him. People mocked
him and said there's no way he's just lying.
And in December, we were vaccinating people.
Well, but let's break that down a little bit,
though, because there's a bunch of pieces there.
So, OK, yes. Trump certainly funded the
manufacture of vaccines and he pretreated
the pre purchasing of vaccines on spec before
we even knew whether these vaccines were
going to be approved. That's that's good.
Any any president would do that. I mean,
to give him too much credit for that seems
a little strange. But when you think about
the the trajectory, there were people saying
December, it's never going to happen. In May,
Goldman Sachs put out to the month an accurate
prediction saying, based on the research that's
being done around the world, we expect health care
workers to start being vaccinated in November.
And here's where I really am curious.
Like what exactly you think Trump did on
vaccination? Because the Phizer vaccine was
developed by Turkish immigrants to Germany.
The Moderna vaccine was sequenced before
Donald Trump even knew what was going on
with the pandemic. So what exactly did Trump
do on the vaccines? Maybe we can figure it out.
Well, I think just pushing on every lever of the
government to get that dominant operation, warp
speed, even, you know, even Dr. Fouche, his boss,
Dr. Francis Collins of the NIH, has said that
operation warp speed deserves a lot of credit.
And so I think when you have a CEO, which
obviously he was for many years as
president, you know, there is just
I think he had just the line of sight to make sure
that this happens. And you can say that, you know,
while this was all in the works for Emerin, aides
have been studied for a decade. So, yes, I mean,
technically, pharmaceuticals are always in the
works. But, you know, pushing that through to
happen in December, no one believe that.
But what did he do to push for that?
Who did he push, though? What did he push?
Well, I can't say exactly what he pushed. It
didn't work in the Trump administration. But what
I can say is that when he said every day we're
working through Operation Warp Speed to get this
done, you know, everything that comes together
through the government, whether it's lifting
regulations or making it easier to get through
the chambers of government. I worked in
Congress for, you know, a decade. And it's
not easy to just get through a very clunky
federal government and bureaucratic system.
But, Amanda, what what regulation that resulted
in vaccines, you're going to have to decide what
you're going to have to give me something specific
is so far he said you don't actually know.
But Trump said he was working hard,
which often means watching Fox News
and tweeting what what what regulations were
lifted to make this happen more quickly.
Look, I again, I'm not going to give specifics
because they don't know exactly what he did
and he never said what he did. So you
don't know he did anything. I'm sorry.
You can't really say he did anything then.
I think that's absolutely false. Now you can
look back and say, well, he said this
or he said that and that wasn't true.
But what the ultimate result was, these vaccines
coming to market. I don't think you can deny that.
Deny which part that the vaccines were made, that
the that the vaccines were made in record time,
in record time they were made. And I am sure that
there are regulations that were lifted. There were
things within the government that were done by
this administration to ensure that that happened
with record speed. I mean, usually it takes a
decade, not forever, on a vaccine and therapeutics
to come to market, not for MRN vaccines.
All right, let's move on, Amanda, because
I do have other things I want to talk about.
But if at some point there's something specific
you can tell me, you know, Trump did rather than
just he was claiming that he was doing stuff,
we will we will reported about claiming I mean,
even when the NIH head like I said, who is Dr.
Fauci boss said Operation Warp Speed deserves
credit. He didn't say Pfizer deserves credit.
He said Operation Warp Speed, Operation Warp
Speed was a function of the Trump administration.
Yes. Now, the two vaccines that were first
approved weren't part of it. They did pre purchase
vaccines, but fine. OK, good. So let's talk a
little bit about policy. My interpretation of the
Republican Party right now and and basically since
the pandemic is that it's essentially a party of
no, it's we don't want to do infrastructure. We
don't want to do coronavirus guidelines. We don't
want to do DACA. We don't want to do tax reform.
We don't want to. So so there's been really no
substantive proposals of policy of what they want.
Certainly, we don't want to do any changes to gun
legislation. Now, I've said I don't know
that it's a bad strategy for Republicans.
And what I mean by that is when you look at a
candidacy like Madison Cawthorn, for example,
his aide or his staff straight up said,
we're not running a policy office,
we're running a communications office. It's memes
and tweets and talking about I can put two guns
on my wheelchair and all this sort of stuff. So
my question is, do you think that this is a viable
long term strategy? It might actually be like, I
don't know that the Republican Party really needs
policy given who's voting for them right now.
Well, the Republican Party doesn't control a
single lever of the government
in Washington right now.
But the last two years of the
Trump administration, they did.
They have the Senate and the White House.
They have the White House and they have the
Senate and the House was controlled by Democrats,
right. So if you're looking if you're talking
about right now because you were talking about
topics for right now, because certainly Trump
tried to do infrastructure and the Democrats said
no. But if you're looking at issues right now, I
think I mean, look, Mitt Romney did an interview
and, you know, Mitt Romney is the king
of rhinos, I guess you could say. I mean,
he would probably be the most moderate,
the most willing to work with Democrats.
And even he has said that going
at this alone on the coronaviruses
relief bill was wrong. He and I believe, as
nine other Republican senators visited with
the president at the beginning of February and
said, Mr. President, let's pare this bill down.
Mr. President, we have other ideas. And President
Biden did not. Not only did he not listen to me,
he didn't pay attention to a single one of their
interests. And it sounds like staff was involved
in this. So the point is, if you want to look back
on President Trump, he passed five coronavirus
bills with bipartisan support and President
Biden didn't do that with bipartisan support.
But, Amanda, that's an that's
an indictment of Republicans.
That's that's an and the fact you're absolutely
right, when it was Trump saying we have to get
money to businesses and the American people,
Democrats didn't say we are going to deny
this to Trump merely because he's in the other
party, because the American people need it. When
Democrats said, OK, well, now it's us, we'll do a
relief bill that's very similar to what Trump did.
Republicans said we're not participating. And
also what you've just said is arguably the biggest
indictment of the obstructionist Republicans
that I am not misinterpreting what I said.
No, I don't think so. Your own facts. Because what
I said is that the Republicans went to visit with
President Biden and he dismissed everything
that they said. He didn't take a single thing
into account. He didn't even work with them.
He didn't even come to the table and say,
let's sit down and talk. They had what concessions
did Trump make? The Democrats largely blamed it
on staff, as did Republicans. The
staff saying we're not interested.
But what concessions did Trump make
to Democrats on the covid bills?
Kennedy Center funding certainly other pieces of
the bill that ultimately the law that Republicans
were raked over the coals for Kennedy Center,
wasn't that like three million bucks or something?
It doesn't matter.
It's the fact that,
you know, this is what's interesting to me.
Yeah. President Trump was impeached by the House
and then three months later, he has Nancy
Pelosi sit down with Steven Manoogian
because they obviously Trump and her didn't
have a relationship. And he said, sit down
and work something out for the American
people. And they did. That's leadership.
You know, you don't pout and say, I don't
like her, so I'm not going to work with her.
Biden did. Biden said, I don't have to work with
you guys because we have 50 50 in common. Leave
the tie breaking vote so I don't have to work
with you guys. So I'm not going to write Trump.
But but I think isn't the difference, Amanda,
that Trump didn't Trump would have done that
if he had had the luxury of having the house.
He just didn't. That's not that's not anything.
I mean, it was just the reality particles.
We can't work in hypotheticals. But I look
at someone who was impeached in the House
by Nancy Pelosi. And three months later,
she sat down with his treasury secretary and
hammered out a deal for the American people.
But the reason she had to sit down with the reason
she had to sit down with Manoogian was Trump,
you know, didn't want to play in the sandbox
with her anymore because of the impeachment.
It's sort of like a criticism of Trump, his
proxy work with her. The ultimate result
was a covert relief bill, wasn't it?
Yeah, just like with Biden. Right.
The ultimate result was a covert
relief bill, a partizan covid relief
fell apart. Think of it really. Is it partizan?
If seventy five percent of Americans support it,
that's tens of millions of Republicans.
What's partizanship and relief
of which 90 percent of this bill does
not go to covid relief we've debunked.
So because we I've debunked that extensively.
I don't want to jump into that. So let's not
jump into that in the few minutes we have left.
What is the policy right now that you think
Republicans should be focusing on? What
policy? Now, I know you're saying, well,
they don't control anything right now. OK, fine.
But when Trump controlled everything, you still
had Democrats proposing things and saying this
is what we would like to see. What are the main
policy points you think would be advantageous to
the Republican Party right now to be working on?
Well, the Republican Party can't
work on anything right now.
It would have been nice if the Democrats
proposed an actual infrastructure bill because,
as you know, infrastructure is a key word for
bipartisanship. Right. But when you have a bill
that's introduced that even Democrats can't
agree on, where the majority of it is not
for actual roads and bridges.
But this isn't my question.
I'm sorry I didn't ask anything.
I'm just saying what should be
the policy priorities of Republicans?
Well, if if Republicans were in control,
I think that lowering health care costs
should be an important demonstration of their
of their efforts to help Americans, especially
after the last year. Americans have consumed a
lot of health care. So making sure that whether
it's deductibles out of pocket, costs are
not prohibitively expensive for Americans and
certainly making sure drug costs come down.
I think you can work in a bipartisan way on that.
Look, I know immigration is the third rail of
politics, but we we have got to re visit
our immigration policies when you have
our immigration policies are tailored
towards the nineteen nineties mentality,
while you have people coming from Central America
and Mexico to the United States to work adults,
you don't have seven year olds walking over
by themselves. You don't have these coyotes
dropping these kids over the fence. That's
the new normal in our immigration. And if
Republicans and Democrats don't tackle
this, that's going to have a huge impact
on the United States and workers in the United
States. We still have high unemployment numbers.
And if we're allowing mass migration to happen
and not doing anything to enforce the borders,
we're going to have problems in all 50 states.
So so health care and immigration would be
your priorities if Republicans
could get things done right now.
I think they just need to sit
down and reevaluate the situation.
I mean, what's happening right now is that you
have coyotes bringing children across the border
because people they don't our policies are not
to send children back. Title 40 to don't send
the children back. They're allowed to stay here.
That's why parents are willing to separate from a
seven year old and allow a stranger to take them
across the border for a better life in America.
We have got to prioritize what are the
needs of the United States. I'm sure
there are needs that the United States has.
And to say, OK, we are going to allow for,
you know, this worker, that worker that we need
and then set immigration policies that way.
But if we're nothing, we're a country
of laws and you have to reevaluate the
entire situation. You can't look at laws
from 30 years ago or 40 years ago and say,
well, this is our immigration
policy. Clearly, it's not working.
Yeah, I mean, it strikes me when you look at for
four Americans, the immigrant, I'm not saying
immigration is not an issue. It just ranks very
low in priorities. The priorities are, you know,
the state of the economy, jobs, wages, health
care. You did mention and I think that that that
certainly would be there, although we might
disagree about the solutions. Immigration is
just quite far down the list for most Americans.
Well, I think that may change when you have in
the month of March alone, one hundred seventy
one thousand migrants coming to our southern
border. Yeah, it's not really changing.
I mean, the polling is pretty steady. It
just is just not that important to most. I'm not
saying it doesn't matter. I just think it's a
very inside politics issue for most people.
I don't know that it's a winning issue for
either party, to be quite frank.
While it may not be a winning issue,
but we have an immigration crisis,
unfortunately, the president, vice
president have not visited the southern border
as bad as it is. They still haven't gone there.
And I understand they don't want the media
to be there to see what it is. What would
they learn from going this? What would they
learn from going that someone can't tell them?
What would they learn from going to the
border that someone can't tell them?
It's it's it's the perception here, the
president, that you have a southern border crisis
and you refuse to go. Got a couple. Harris has
been tasked with this. What has she done in the
last two weeks since she has been tasked with
this to show that this is an important issue?
There's a crisis on our border. Seven year olds
are being dropped over fences to be able to come
into the United States. Well, no, that's fine.
That's fine. But so but you're saying it's up to
the going to the border is about optics.
They could learn everything from this
transparency. There's been a
media blackout, and that's not
transparency. This was supposed to be the most
transparent administration and it hasn't been.
Yeah. So I do think that they need to be
more transparent with the video from some of
the facilities they've released some but but not
others. So that's a beautiful point of agreement,
Amanda, on which on which we can end. Amanda
Macchi, attorney and Republican strategist,
telling us many different things, which I am sure
our audience will find very interesting. Amanda,
I really appreciate your time.
Thank you.